[Musique]
à ceux qui s'interrogent sur le thème
quand même
macron il plaît à droite qui pleurait au
centre fait une politique que vous
n'avez pas eu le courage de faire je
prends de trois exemples il est très
simple d'abord nous on n'aurait pas pris
ces mesures sur le fuel et on n'aurait
pas pris ces mesures sur le 80 km heure
parce que nous on sait que plus de la
moitié des français vivent dans des
communes de moins de 2000 habitants
nous on sait que près de 40% des
français vivent dans des communes de
moins de 2500 habitants juillet tout de
suite on n'aurait pas fait la même
politique
je suis et sinon fait pas de politique
absolument convaincu qu'on aurait fait
mieux et on aurait certainement évité
les sujets qui font aujourd'hui avec le
co vide où l'état n'a pas été à la
hauteur
macron ne peut pas dire que l'état a
résisté soit l'état qu'à résister c'est
les français qui ont été courageux sont
les entreprises qui ont été à
l'initiative
ce sont les maires qui ont été
protecteur ce sont les régions qui ont
été à gilles ce sont les départements
qui ont garanti la solidarité nationale
mais l'état n'a pas été à la hauteur ni
en anticipation ni en prévision n'est en
protection donc pour ceux qui veulent
faire de la politique
et pour ceux qui parmi vous veulent
s'engager dans les prochains combats
je peux vous dire il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à dire pour amener
les gens sur le chemin du partage de la
fée verte de ce que veut dire être fiers
d'être républicain cette passion de la
république étant vous c'est un devoir
il n'y a rien de plus beau que de voir
cette salle on ne voit plus que vous
regard mais on imagine vos sourires et
on espère également votre bonne humeur
y a rien de plus beau que cet engagement
vous fait il n'y a rien de plus beau que
de servir la république et rien de plus
beau que d'exercer des mandats et rien
de plus beau que d'être un militant
les militants ils doivent être honorés
doivent être respectées nous les élus on
leur doit tout on leur doit tout et on
ne l'oublient pas
et et dans les années passées certains
qui ont fait d'autres choix par
opportunisme
il faut dire qu'ils avaient peut-être le
dictionnaire des girouettes et du
maréchal têtards qui concluait son
parcours en ayant servi tous les régimes
après les avoir triés travailler avec la
même constance professionnels il est
vrai qu'en retournant sa veste
on attrape jamais un rhume et bien
laissé le maréchal de toutes les tares
de côté
restez comme vous êtes justement avec
votre veste vous habib république un
profond fier
regardez tout le monde droit devant avec
beaucoup de bonheur beaucoup de
compassion beaucoup d'empathie mais
aussi beaucoup de détermination
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m